what do you think about this whole chaos
of gamestop and wall street bets and
then
today we found out about the market
trying to shut the traders down is this
a digital form of anarchy
uh i don't know if it's anarchy per se
but it's certainly um
any time people's pompous posturing
and their be i've been following it
closely because i know
once i sit down for and follow this
story through from everyone who's been
forwarding to me
like my pants are gonna be ruined
because i'm just it's gonna
downright pornographic like everyone's
like you don't understand this is what
you've been predicting and calling for
so i'm i need to sit down where i have
nice
uh pants you wanted a separate ball
ball and yeah sheath underwear yeah yeah
yeah
because this is this is everyone's like
you this is exactly what you like
um whenever pomposity and pretension
which is a form of deceit is undermined
especially in a populist way or just by
in a clever way
this is something i absolutely adore i
don't think this is all exclusive to you
know anarchism per se
um but it's wonderful um
so i and what else is very useful
is it's a lot i think we're a lot closer
to brave new world than 1984.
it's a lot easier to manipulate a
population through pleasure than through
force and through oppression if you just
give them a little bit of cheese and
you give them a job it's going to be
very hard to get them to be riled up and
you could just milk them
all day long so whenever
if you're going to win a war as i intend
to
or i hope to it's of enormous utility
when they take the gloves off and they
have to demonstrate
that underneath they're perfectly happy
to use brute force or whatever
just be unsophisticated like okay we're
just gonna shut it down
and then it becomes a lot easier to
demonstrate that these people don't
give a damn about you uh they're out
looking for their own best interest
which is their
prerogative but this pretense this
corporate bs
that we're all in this together and blah
blah blah it's just complete sociopathy
and nonsense
and a lot of people will never
appreciate this and that's fine but you
don't want them on your team anyway
a lot of people who can be one over
they're gonna see things like this
and they're gonna be like okay like i'm
starting to get it like this is just
a complete facade i'm
trying to work out what the particular
quirk is in
with my makeup i think it is partly
being british and enjoying the procedure
i'm also moderately orderly i'm an
orderly guy my bedroom tends to be tidy
and i put things away in rows in the
cupboard and stuff like that
um and for me i enjoy watching people
like
alex jones i enjoy learning about
alternative world views and i enjoy
questioning at least indulging myself in
thought
experiments around what is the state's
ulterior motives and stuff like that
but it does feel usually a little bit
like
watching a pantomime you're like yeah
yeah like that looks good but i know
that the
guys will go backstage and take their
clothes off and it'll all just be normal
like the way that i know the world's to
be once it's kind of all finished
but increasingly there are things
happening and this is such a stark
example
you see the market move which is
quantifiable which makes it really
interesting because you can actually
see what's happening it's not just a
sentiment right it's not just how people
feel it's
quantifiable metrics there in front of
you and you see this market move
and then these different structures of
power start to come in so
robin hood decide that they're going to
stop trading and then other platforms
say that they're going to stop trading
and then there's questions about circuit
breakers being put into the market so
that they can stop the price moving at
all
he's seeing people 50 of robin hood
clients
hold some game stop stock
so by stopping that trading not allowing
anyone else to buy you're just sending
the price in one direction
like it and then the the most
interesting thing about it all is that
when you have
a distributed network of people who have
far too much time on their hands
and are smarter than they are kind of
moronic like they all call themselves
like a proud community of artists
but like you don't want to [ __ ] with
those people they know they're not going
to forget anything
they they know they know what they're
talking about they just can't look you
in the eye whilst they say it
i whilst i had a chapter about this in
my last book about gamergate
because part of the evangelical left is
the idea that these prince political
principles have to be
implemented in every aspect of your life
including sci-fi
and fantasy and movies so even places
you go to escape the earth
you know these edicts have to be
followed through one of the examples i
used
which you know you want to talk about
autism i got it right here was on star
trek they finally had a they
finally that's the word they used had a
black vulcan
and if you want to go full autistic the
idea that human race is evolved in
parallel on other planets
is absolutely
right if you're gonna if you're gonna
look at it from that perspective from
their perspective no
you have to have diversity even though
if it makes no sense there was a video
game
that took place in the middle ages of of
of europe
and they were complaining there wasn't
enough diversity there as well so it
becomes
completely you know very top-down and uh
um
uh um nonsensical so this when
you know the corporate journalists came
for this community
like you were saying this is an entire
population with too much time in their
hands
who also spend their time trying to
figure out
how the the enemy in this case in the
video games the enemy works
and what weapons do i need to do to
conquer this enemy they don't look at it
in terms
so it becomes a game to them it's like
okay let's do a b testing let's try
different tactics
and it's decentralized so you have an
army of these people it's like al qaeda
right there's no
you can't kill the one guy and
everything falls away they're used to
this they've been training for it their
entire lives
right they have this this is our moment
right
but no i mean literally just spending
hours trying to accomplish these goals
that have been set for them
with adversaries in the way so it's a
beautiful
um you know one of the things you and i
talk about
you know uh personally is
kind of this whole generation who
they are getting more attention but
they're kind of being told that they
don't exist
are these kind of alienated young males
right so
in some cases it goes in a very very bad
direction you know you kind of have this
white nationalism
this sense of oh your life is bad
because there's too many minorities and
now
this racial identity means you can look
at what your grandfather supposedly did
now you're a great person
but this is another example you could be
at your
desktop your what they call them like
workstation
and you can cause systemic carnage
against some really nasty people and
have lulls at the same time isn't that
great
so i i am a big fan of uh
i don't know about the specifics of this
case to be honest but
i'm a big fan of this ethos it is
i think the first time that you heard
about it was me telling you perhaps or
maybe trey is also a big
wall street bets follower but i spoke
about it last year i'd seen some mad
[ __ ] that they'd done last year
these guys what is it they call like
4chan founder bloomberg terminal
they call themselves and uh yeah it
really is
they're they're your people they're your
people that could be the party of malice
there there's 3.5 million of them in
that subreddit now
it's it's a wonderful thing and that's
what else is hilarious they're like
well we'll just shut up shut down this
subreddit as if
somehow on the internet there's any
shortage of places to create communities
when you have 3.5 million people let's
propose one percent of our programmers
like how hard is it going to be where
all they're interested in doing is being
able to text each other
they're not trying to build spaceships
they just need a space to exchange
information
where there's a worldwide infrastructure
designed to facilitate this as you said
earlier it's glorious
did you see that ja rule got involved
today i did
i i'm not really sure who he is for
racist reasons i'm assuming he's a
rapper he is well yeah he was his trend
was
filed under hip-hop i mean that's fairly
that's fairly racist by
twitter it had nothing to do with
hip-hop like you know he's an
entrepreneur he's a budding entrepreneur
he's part of fire festival
yeah someone oh okay someone posted the
dave chappelle bit
going like why the [ __ ] do i care about
what jar rule thinks at this moment it's
from one of his old stand-ups
and it was just an entire thread of
people posting that below
it's i i think that's also this great
thing you know blue pilled red pilled
it's like you're sitting at home and you
have some people have political
perspectives
of one kind or another but then it's
like why am i
getting political orders from actors who
are puppets made out of meat
like it makes no sense on any level and
it's such an insincere
propaganda technique that i think people
increasingly and i'm doing what i can
start to resent it it would make more
sense if
someone was a writer of these sitcoms
because writers have to create a
narrative
writers have to be coherent and logical
writers to some extent have to be in
touch with the
reality an actor you don't really
you have no original thoughts or the
thoughts you do have aren't part of your
[Music]
job
you